we have all heard the phrase let's make
the world a better place
but how exactly do we do that well
i have an answer we reach into people's
lives and we make a change to them that
matters
and sometimes it's just a little
inspiration by seeing
also someone else do that and then we
follow their lead
meet greg daley a man who went from
delivering newspapers to delivering
groceries for those in need
during quarantine he saw people in need
and chose to step in
so welcome greg hi
how are you hi thank you for being here
my pleasure will you let us know around
what time you started doing this
right around when the pandemic started i
guess mid-march
was the beginning of it um mika who's
our fantastic producer gave me a great
detail too where she said that
some of the people that you were
delivering newspapers to
who were elderly were asking if you
could bring
the paper up closer to them rather than
just flinging it
out the door or car or something yeah i
got a call
one one evening from one of my customers
asking if i would throw the paper closer
to her house
and uh i of course said yes a couple
days later
i was standing in a grocery store and
she just kind of popped into my head
and you know i wondered you know i
thought to myself let me give her a call
see if she needs anything
and uh i called her she took me up on it
and moments later she called me back
and that was kind of the impetus for the
whole thing to start a day later i put
out a note
realizing that i had two customers that
needed help
and the response was uh was incredible
and you folded that note
into the newspapers you were delivering
i put it in uh
each newspaper i delivered that's that
morning it was about 800 newspapers yeah
and now you're helping around 130
seniors
it's you know been very consistently you
know in in the 130
range yeah so how do you do that wait
take me through your day i want
an hour-by-hour little bullet point
really quickly do you mind
i get up at four o'clock in the morning
i deliver the papers typically the
customers are
emailing me their lists you know so
email's tough for some so a lot of them
just hand write their list and leave it
on notes
but they leave it in their on their door
in their mailbox so when i'm done with
the papers i'll i'll go back and i'll
pick up the notes
we'll shop for them we'll deliver them
and then
then i start my day at work i do
fortunately have
now 12 volunteers that are helping me
which has been incredible it's been an
incredible part of this whole thing is
to find people that were willing to jump
on board with what i was doing
well that just goes with my whole theory
that you know there
is no i in team and a dream is
sort of an idea a wish a lofty goal and
then you meet another person
and it starts to grow and that little
kindle becomes a beautiful flame
there's such a large tapestry of what
happens
in the world every single day all day
long
but one of the biggest things i really
wanted to do on the show
was find stories like yours
because we need to hear that people are
good and that we're taking care of each
other which i believe is what we're all
here to do
and that there's a functionality behind
it because some of us have hopes and
dreams of being a better person and
pitching in
but we don't always know what to do well
some of us need a push
you know i mean i think you know and i'm
i'd like to think and you know i
gather from you that you know you're one
that likes to to
put you know that someone people need a
nudge a little push in the right
direction to do
well and i i truly believe that you know
every day
we get presented as individuals with an
opportunity to help
um and multiple times a day depending on
your day
and you know if you just take that
opportunity one time a day
we'll be a much much much better place
greg really you've impressed us so much
and sometimes we all struggle with what
can we do how can we help
and i think you're the perfect example
and since you so selflessly spend
you know almost a hundred dollars a week
on gas getting these groceries to
everyone
well we got some help from our friends
at none other than
wawa i love this so much i'm so excited
wawa
is known for community support and
huawei's company's roots are in the new
jersey area
but they have over 250 stores in the
garden state so
greg wawa is giving you a 5 000
gift card to show
their support and gratitude for what you
are doing
and to help enable you do the great work
that you're
are doing kidding me uh that's
oh my god that's incredible thank you
greg
for everything that you do for being
that human example
you